JAY SMITH: Welcome
to CE Chat hosted
by Cloud OnAir, live
webinars from Google Cloud.
Just a reminder, we are hosting
these webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Jay Smith.
I'm a Cloud Customer
Engineer here at Google,
and today, I will be
talking to David Aronchick.
Nice to meet you.
DAVID ARONCHICK:
Thank you very much.
JAY SMITH: Today, we're
going to be talking
a little bit about Kubeflow.
And just a reminder, guys, we
encourage you to ask questions
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them,
and we'll get to some of
them at the end as well.
So let's get started.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Great.
Thanks so much, Jay.
As you mentioned, we're
here to talk about Kubeflow.
That's machine
learning on Kubernetes
or, as we like to
say, Cloud Native ML.
And I think it's a
really interesting time
to be talking about machine
learning and Kubernetes
together.
The reality is that everyone
hears about how great ML is.
They want to adopt
it and, you know,
immediately make changes
to their business.
And I think the problems
that a lot of people
have today is it can
be very complicated,
and there's a big distance
between the actual vision of ML
and getting it going
off the ground.
A lot of people today,
you know, say ML is great.
They hear about it.
It's in the news.
They hear it from their
colleagues and friends.
They want to go and solve a
bunch of problems very quickly.
JAY SMITH: It's definitely
a big buzz word,
and everybody's trying
to invest in it.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
And the reason is because
of things like this.
This is something that
Google did specifically.
This is Google engineers,
Google data scientists
who spend their entire life
getting great at data centers,
using renewable energy, using
the latest technologies.
And then they go and they
attach an ML solution
to the problem to handle
the power and cooling
and management of
their data centers.
And almost instantly,
they were able to save
40%, a huge amount of money,
by attaching machine learning
models to these frameworks.
So they were able to make a
huge difference, already better
than the best in almost
any industry just
by using this machine
learning technology.
And this is something
that a lot of industries
are really excited about.
And they are like, well, geez.
You know, I'd love to
get some of that as well.
Unfortunately, machine
learning is very hard.
It's not just because
I'm terrible at math.
It is because this is the
reality of machine learning.
On one side, you have
that magical AI goodness,
which is so easy to see, where
the benefits are so powerful.
And on the other side, you see
where most folks are today.
They, you know, have old
style legacy infrastructure
they need to integrate with.
They have very large
data sets that they're
trying to manage and maintain
and make the most use of.
And there's so much
distance between, you know,
where they are today
and the magical AI
goodness of the future.
JAY SMITH: Well, that's
pretty extensive, there.
Just-- not a magic wand
like a lot of us think.
Just throw good-- throw
pictures and get a result.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Yeah.
No, no question.
There really is no magic
wand, and the reason
is there is no magic wand
is because you basically
have this reality.
There are two
sides of the world.
Side one is where you have
these do-it-yourself solutions,
where you set it up from
scratch, where you integrate
with legacy systems.
And then, once you've
finally done all that work,
which can be weeks,
months, years
in order to do
that, you often have
to do it all over again
as you need to migrate,
as you change your
solution, as anything
in your system overall changes.
The other side of the
coin is around hosted.
And I should say, this is
not all hosted solutions,
but certainly this is the trend.
In the first five
minutes, it looks great.
You're immediately able
to make progress, change
the way you do your business
and at least experiment
with the model.
But then in the
next five years, you
face everything you did in
the do-it-yourself scenario.
You have the same
customization issues,
you have the same legacy systems
that you need to integrate.
Plus now you're locked in.
You've used a framework
or a model that
only works on a single cloud,
and you're kind of out of luck.
So the question is, haven't
we heard this story before?
And the reality is we have.
Before I came to
work on Kubeflow,
I ended up I was working
on the Kubernetes platform.
And Kubernetes, when it
first came out in 2015,
it was a very,
very similar story.
The reality was that containers
and Kubernetes in 2015
and before was a highly
bespoke solution.
You had to come up with
a lot of custom tooling,
frameworks, and so on in order
to get things up and running.
And in order to wire
everything together,
it became an enormous
amount of work.
You had to have entire
teams dedicated to that.
When Kubernetes
came along in 2015,
you now started to have
a standard set of APIs
and native ways to handle the
complexities of distributed
computing.
And that really
changed the game.
People started to leverage
the Kubernetes native platform
to go the next level up.
In Kubecon in Austin
2017 in last December,
we talked about some of the
ways that we really have
started to unlock that future.
JAY SMITH: You guys were just
at Kubecon EU as well, right?
DAVID ARONCHICK: That's
absolutely right.
And the way that we
were able to unlock
that future was with these
native extension points.
You have all these
various components
that operate in layers
from all those run
times and plug-ins, moving
up the stack to the new API
layer, application
layer, governance layer,
so on and so forth.
But each of these
had very clean lines,
and they enabled
people to swap out
the things that made the most
sense for running Kubernetes.
And what that
ultimately resulted in
is people being able to run
cloud native applications.
Applications for
running containers
that used all the
stat things that
were provided to them
without any customization.
And so what we would like to
propose around machine learning
is Cloud Native ML,
a similar approach
to this system which adopts
the core components of what
makes containers and
Kubernetes so strong.
That is composability,
portability, and scalability.
So for each of those, I think
it's worth just a moment
to talk about how they
apply to machine learning.
When you think
about composability,
first, you think about building
a model around your machine
learning solution.
And that's certainly
something very interesting.
Whether or not it's TensorFlow,
Caffe, CNTK, MXNet, PyTorch,
you name it.
There are many, many different
ways to build a model.
People get very
excited about that.
But the reality is when it comes
to building a machine learning
solution, it ends up being
much much more than that.
You end up having all these
various components that you
need to integrate, and
each of those components
are often slightly
different based on the data
scientist working on it.
JAY SMITH: That's
definitely not magic there.
That is a lot of work
and a lot of knowledge
and a lot of skills needed to
make any of this work, right?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Yeah.
And I think that's
exactly right.
Data scientists have
skills in particular areas.
They want to use
the frameworks that
are familiar to them, the tools
that are familiar to them,
in each of these various stages.
From data, to experimentation,
to production,
and ultimately rolling it out.
And I think that
really speaks to how
you have to have these
things be composable.
So if you have a data
scientist in one organization,
they can use standard
techniques and then
swap them for a different set
of techniques for different data
scientists and different work.
JAY SMITH: All right.
DAVID ARONCHICK: So
that's kind of category 1.
We want them to be composable
and let people choose
what makes sense to them.
Category 2 is
around portability.
So earlier, we talked
about all the steps
involved a machine
learning framework,
but even that is just the start.
Then, you start to talk about
all the elements in your stack.
OS drivers, run times,
so on and so forth.
It gets very, very complicated.
And to set up even one
of these environments
can be very challenging.
Yet, the average data scientist
often faces multiple of these.
They might start on their
laptop or on a private rig.
They might move to a training
solution, a training cluster,
and then finally into the
cloud for final production
and training at scale.
And to have a
portable solution that
works in all of these
places would greatly
speed their ability
to work instead
of having to have them
set up a custom bespoke
solution for each one.
And then finally, we
get to scalability.
Scalability is often thought of
as just the number of machines,
but really in machine learning,
it's much more than that.
It's accelerators, things
like GPUs, TPUs, CPUs,
the speed of your
disk and networking,
whether or not it's a
fixed disk, SSD, so on.
And then it's not
just physical assets,
but it's actually human beings.
How do you scale people
with different skill sets?
Interns, SUI's, data
scientists, researchers, IT ops.
How do you scale various
teams if they're geolocated?
Even if they're sitting
right next to each other,
but they happen to
have different focuses.
And ultimately, how do
you get more experiments?
How do you run them
simultaneously and so on?
So those are the
three things that we
think make up Cloud Native ML.
Composability, portability,
and scalability.
And what we think
is a great solution
for that is containers
and Kubernetes.
That's really what
they were designed for.
Loosely coupling a number of
services together and making it
very production
ready and scalable.
However, if you want to use
machine learning on Kubernetes,
it can be very challenging.
There are a lot of core
components that are involved.
Containers, packaging, service
endpoints, persistent volumes.
These are often
very new concepts
to people who are familiar
really with just VMs and disks.
And even worse, if you get
into the data scientist realm
where they really just want
to focus on their experiment.
JAY SMITH: Right.
I remember when I first started
getting into containers.
It was very different
than what I used to do,
and I actually started
using containers just
as kind of like makeshift
VMs, not using them
to their full extent.
And, you know, first you
have to learn that aspect.
Then, you have to now
learn the machine learning
or, as you said, data
scientists just care about data.
DAVID ARONCHICK:
Yeah, absolutely.
So that's why we
introduced Kubeflow, a way
to set up a complicated but
composable, portable, machine
learning framework in a
way that takes advantage
of all the advantages in the
climate of machine learning.
We want to make it
easy for everyone
to develop, deploy,
and manage portable,
distributed ML on Kubernetes.
And it's really important
that we mention that last term
about focusing on Kubernetes.
Anywhere there is a Kubernetes
deployment, this runs great.
So whether or not
that's Google or on-prem
or on VMware or on
other clouds, as long
as there is a Kubernetes
conformant cluster,
you can set up and run Kubeflow.
And I will show you how
that works in just a second.
The way to think about
it is thinking back
to all those various
stacks we had earlier.
You have Kubernetes
as this base layer.
You can be sure that
it runs everywhere.
That's a core vision of
the Kubernetes project.
Then, you describe your
overall complex deployment
using Kubeflow native tooling.
And you're able to stamp
out Kubeflow in all
of these various locations.
And specifically,
as Jay mentioned,
at KubeCon EU on
Friday, we announced
Kubeflow 0.1, a significant
new milestone for us
to get out the door and
start helping people really
start to use production
or excuse me,
use Kubeflow in
their enterprises
to solve problems today.
Today in the box, we
have a Jupyter notebook.
We have distributed
training in the box.
We use multi framework
model serving.
And I should really
stress right now
that though flow is
the name, we really
think about that as machine
learning flow and not
TensorFlow.
We support Caffe, PyTorch, and
we have lots more frameworks
coming soon.
Our goal is to really
support whatever our data
scientists needs using standard
packaging for customizing
it yourself.
And so with that, I'd like to
show you just a very brief demo
about Kubeflow.
Let me just swap over here.
You'll forgive me, this was
a live demo this morning,
but just because we have
to run on this laptop,
we're going to use a recorded
video of the one I did earlier.
So what you have here is
a standard Yelp analysis
or excuse me, Yelp
sentiment database.
This is public data,
and in the public data,
basically there's all
the various results
from Yelp content.
And they have large
comment databases,
and you're able to see
through and page through all
the various information.
In this case, you have a
variety of different things.
And looking at this middle one.
It's a lot of
words, but really, I
think, as humans, we're able
to see that it works properly.
A little on the pricey
end for baked goods,
but the baked goods were good.
Also, their coffee
products are great.
These are a lot of words,
but clearly as humans, we're
able to see it.
However, when you apply this
to a standard machine learning
framework or excuse
me, a standard solution
today, it may not look as,
you know, as obviously correct
for these folks.
You know, it's often
very, very hard
using a regular
expression analysis
to have a system go
and look at this.
So let's actually try.
And we hit the
prediction sentiment,
and it didn't come
back very well.
So that's not exactly
what we want to see.
I think it's actually kind of
funny when you think about it.
What you might come up with
for a solution here is,
well, maybe I'll just do some
regular expression matching
against the underlying code.
And looking at this regular
expression matching,
you're looking at it and
you're like, well, all right.
You know, oh geez.
Someone commented
out good and great.
We're just going to
try and find things
where it says annoying,
terrible, and bad.
You know, not ideal.
It kind of works, but
you know, obviously, it
missed on some of
the things that we
were looking for earlier.
So what I'd like
to do is, I'd like
to use machine learning to
try and solve this problem.
The Google team, the Google
Brain team as we call them--
actually, I think that
is literally their name--
released an open source
machine learning framework
called Tensor2Tensor that
is very, very well designed
or excuse me, kind of
pre-built for handling
a lot of these language issues.
And you can see here this
is an entire set of things.
It describes how to install
and run these various things.
Which is obviously
pretty complicated.
But you can see
some of the things
that it's really good at.
It's really good at
things like image language
or image classification,
language modeling,
sentiment analysis, and so on.
And so really, that
sentiment analysis
is what we're going to
try and set up here.
That's just a demo script.
Everything here is
really happening.
That's just a demo script
to kick everything off.
And what we're
going to do first is
we're going to set up a standard
machine learning framework
on your local cluster using
something called Minikube.
Minikube is an application
that runs on your laptop,
and it creates a real life
Kubernetes cluster running
locally so that you have
as little difference
between your laptop
and ultimately
what you run into in production.
So what we're going
to do here is first,
we're going to start
using Minikube.
Minikube is already
running in the background.
I'm going to switch
my Kube control
to point at that
Minikube, and then I'm
going to run a deployment
of Kubeflow Core.
That is a standard package
that we have in Kubeflow.
You just execute
literally that command,
that KS there
stands for Ksonnet.
And you apply it to
Minikube, and what happens
immediately is it
goes and deploys
all of the various
components that you
might want for a core
machine learning framework.
It gives you TensorFlow.
It gives you JupyterHub.
It gives you an
ambassador for HTTP proxy.
It gives you a
distributed job framework,
and it gives you a dashboard.
So really, really powerful
right out of the box.
It gets going.
And what, like I said, it starts
up with a Jupyter notebook.
In this case, it accepts
any user name and password
so you don't want to
enable this to the web.
And then you get
it going, but you
can see here you're
able to go and select
an entire array
of various tools.
We come with a number of
different packages built in
for running your kernels,
whether or not it's CPU or GPU,
a whole variety of
TensorFlow frameworks
with various notebooks.
And then it also
allows you to do things
like set the CPUs, set the
memory, extra resources,
including things like GPUs,
which is obviously very, very
important.
So with that, we're not going to
do interactive Jupiter training
today.
We've already decided
to use TensorFlow,
and it's pretty good.
So we're going to do what's
called distributed training.
That's where you
take that model,
that Tensor2Tensor model.
You package it in a
container, and then you're
able-- you know, with a very
few amount of commands--
and you're able to distribute
it across an entire cluster.
And that means
that it's up to you
to now decide how many
nodes you want to use
as part of your training.
So if you want it to go faster,
you could add 10, 100, 1,000.
If you wanted to go slowly or
you're more cost conscious,
you could use just two or three.
So we'll go and we'll do that.
To run a distributed training,
you need to do one command--
or you need to do two things.
The first thing you need to
do is set some parameters,
and this is really where
the power of Kubeflow
comes from or
starts to highlight.
First, you saw me set up
an entire framework earlier
using a very straightforward
command to select
the package that I want.
But now, I'm able to set
parameters for the specific job
that I'm going to run without
changing any of that underlying
code.
And these are parameters
you understand.
You know, whether or not
there's a GPU present,
how many workers
there are, where
I'm storing my data, all
these various things.
You're able to do it just like
setting any other variable.
So I'm setting up for
a distributed training,
and here I am.
I'm kicking off with this
same command you saw earlier.
I'm kicking off
Tensor2Tensor, which
I have built into a container.
And just to prove that it
is, in fact, running here,
you can see that the
Tensor2Tensor job is running.
It's running against
CPUs because I'm only
using my local laptop and
I want to have it run.
And here, you can see you
get the exact same logs
that you would run from
any normal TensorFlow
job with all the appropriate
information there.
Again, nothing special here.
This is just--
I wouldn't ask you to
read this wall of text.
I'm just pointing
out that this really
is a real live job running,
and you saw me execute just,
you know, four or five commands
to get it off the ground.
All right.
So now that I've done
that, it's running OK.
But what you saw is you
didn't see any syntax errors.
You know that it ran properly.
Maybe it converged,
maybe it didn't.
That's OK.
All I'm really doing
on my local laptop
is making sure that
this does run properly
without any errors.
What I'd like to do now
is, now that I said,
hey, this does run
great, I'd like
to take it to a
cluster in the cloud
to run that training
very, very quickly.
And so in this case, I've set
up a GKE, a Google Kubernetes
Engine cluster.
It runs on Google
Cloud, obviously,
and it's going to run with
two different sets of nodes.
First, it's going to
run with GPU nodes.
And those are the absolute
latest from NVIDIA
with a whole variety of
different nodes and node pools.
You can see here that we're
using eight NVIDIA Tesla
p100 accelerators
attached to those nodes.
And then second,
we're also going
to use the brand new
TPUs from Google.
Let me just do that.
You can see the p100 there.
And second, we're
going to use the TPUs.
Those are the tensor
processing units
attached to the same cluster.
And we're going to run
those jobs simultaneously
across those clusters to
see which one runs first.
Sometimes, p100s run better.
Sometimes TPUs run better.
It doesn't matter
to us because we
have-- it's so easy to
set up multiple of these.
We can run the
experiment ourselves,
and you can see here this
is what the TPUs look like.
And they support
TensorFlow version 1.7,
so we'll make sure to
support that in our nodes.
OK.
So now that we've kicked it
off, we're going to run this.
And now, we're going to
switch to that cluster
that I just showed
you, and we're
going to apply that exact same
deployment that I ran locally.
And again, this is part
of the power of Kubeflow.
I don't have to
make big changes.
In fact, in this case,
I'm making no changes.
From the exact same
deployment I had locally,
I'm able to deploy
to my GKE cluster.
That makes it easy
for me to get started,
easy for me to have
reproduceable machine learning
and data science.
And you can see there,
it's updating it
in the cluster on the cloud.
Next, I'm going to kick
off my GPU training.
Again, I'm going to
use that same package
that I had built
earlier for running
on my local machine that
was running against CPUs.
But this time, I'm going to
change the parameters and say,
no.
In fact, I do have
GPUs on these nodes,
and I want you to pick it up.
And then, I'm also
going to change here
where the data is
stored, and again, I'm
doing that based on parameters.
Not changing code.
And I apply those,
and those should
be kicked off momentarily.
Second, I'm also going
to deploy that to TPUs.
And so again, I'm going
to change a parameter
to make sure that this new
job is running against TPUs.
And I'm also going to use
a slightly different build.
Unfortunately today, you have
to build different versions
based on whether or not
you're using GPUs and TPUs.
Again, for data
scientists, this is great
because it means you're able
to package and describe exactly
how you want that model to run.
OK.
So we're kicking
that off as well.
This time, I don't have
to go into my local logs
to do it because Google
Kubernetes Engine actually
has a great UI for me
to explore what jobs
are running simultaneously.
So here, you can see all the
logs, the current loss rate--
it's happening very quickly.
It's saving checkpoints into
that Google Storage bucket,
and you can see here all
the various jobs that
are running simultaneously.
OK.
So the jobs are kicked off.
They're running.
Again, we're not
going to bore you
with how long it takes
to run all these.
I'm going to use, in
fact, TensorBoard.
And in this case, TensorBoard
also ships with Kubeflow.
It's built in, and it shows you
how quickly things are stepping
through the overall
process and how quickly
things are resolving.
Great UI.
It helps your data
scientists really debug
and understand what's
going on under the hood.
And most importantly,
it ships in the box.
You saw-- literally
exactly what you saw
earlier is what's running now.
I didn't have to do any special
new packaging or distributions
to run this, and yet, it
ran great on my laptop.
It ran great on GPUs and TPUs.
In this case, we're able
to see, roughly speaking,
about 16 and 1/2 steps
per second for the TPUs,
and you saw earlier about three
steps per second for the GPUs.
So in one command,
I'm able to test
against multiple
different accelerators.
And in this case, the TPUs came
out about five times faster.
Really, really powerful stuff,
and we're really, really
excited to show you.
And then finally, like I said,
the demo needs to be short.
So we'll try and jump
forward here a little bit.
Also included in
the Kubeflow box,
I promise, you know,
it's not unlimited,
but there is a lot
of stuff in there.
It's TensorFlow Serving.
So in this case, you
have TensorFlow Serving,
which means we're going
to take that trained model
and we're actually going to
will serve it and attach it
to that Yelp review
we saw earlier.
We deploy that serving, and
now we're going to, excuse me,
we're going to swap over.
You can see here in the
Google Kubernetes Engine UI
that Tensor2Tensor
serving is running
and ready to receive results.
So we'll go back
to our Yelp review.
This is a different web page
that is now designed to use ML.
Here were the original results.
All wrong.
One that was happy when
it should've been sad,
one that was sad when it
should have been happy,
and then the final
one that was happy
when it should have been sad.
And we're going to reattach
that, swap back over
and go over to the UI, and hit
the predict sentiment again.
And it now comes out
correct, and so that's really
the summary of Kubeflow.
It's a very, very
straightforward framework
that really empowers you to
make decisions about machine--
the best machine learning
framework for you
without having to worry
about any of the stuff
under the hood.
JAY SMITH: I mean,
that's definitely--
I mean, it seems like it's leaps
and bounds for machine learning
because I can, like you
showed with Minikube,
run the cluster on my
machine and whether it
be servers in a cold load,
or servers in my office,
or even a cloud, Google
Cloud, I can just
move it and continue running
my models with more power.
And then, of course,
it comes packaged
with all those great little
tools, like TensorBoard.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
And that really is it.
When you go and talk to almost
any data scientist in the world
today, they often have
very dispersed environments
that they'll need to run in.
They want to be moved
to wherever the data is.
They may have petabytes of
data that they want to process,
and that may not be in
this cloud or that cloud.
And what they're really looking
to do is get to an environment
where they can think
purely about the model
and let the separation in IT
ops, you know, take care of it
for them.
What you didn't see there were
some really important points.
First, you didn't see
any bespoke solutions.
These weren't custom,
new ML frameworks.
They weren't brand new
open source solutions.
We're using existing
very popular open source
technologies today that you can
use or swap out for your own.
Things aren't, like, insanely
tightly wired together.
Second, you didn't see any
cloud-specific technology.
Even when we were deploying
to Google Kubernetes Engine,
we were using the
exact same software
that we had running locally.
All we did was swap
out our parameters.
And then finally, you didn't see
any forking of the Kubernetes
APIs.
Meaning, anywhere you have a
Kubernetes compliant cluster,
it's going to run great.
And really, this
is going to empower
a brand new set
of data scientists
and other people in the world.
There's a great
story out of Sweden
where a group of scientists
were able to look
at a number of data and identify
that what they were doing wrong
was they were plowing the wrong
streets at the wrong time.
And stay at home
parents and women
who happened to not
be at work that day
ended up being injured
far more frequently
because in light
snow situations,
they would be tripping and
falling on sidewalks when
cars could actually handle it.
So by looking at
the data scientists
and using frameworks
just like Kubeflow,
they were able to
see that they could
make a huge impact
in people's lives
without any change
or any other budget.
Just by changing the
order, and that's really
what we need to do as
far as using Kubeflow.
It's really empowering
everyone at the various levels
to make smart
decisions, and help them
make the world a better place.
And by doing that, by focusing
on giving people clean layers,
by giving the data
scientists the ability
to make these decisions,
they're able to hand off
to the next layer above them
to make even better decisions
and really change the world.
We are just getting
started with Kubeflow.
It is 0.1.
It's a little early for
running in production.
Even though all the components
of Kubeflow are battle tested,
things like TensorFlow,
as I mentioned,
TensorBoard, Jupiter
and things like
that, have been out
for many, many months,
Kubeflow is still brand new.
But we do have a lot
of people helping.
You can see a small subset of
people who are contributing
to the platform today.
And then what's next in Kubeflow
0.2, which we hope to have out
by this summer, we're going
to make it even easier
to set it up, integrate with
more and deeper Kubernetes
features, and a lot
better packages.
But really, the feature
we'd like to have
is the one we haven't heard yet.
There are many, many
data scientists out there
that are trying to
solve the problem,
and Kubeflow is entirely
an open source project.
It is, though Google
contributed to it significantly,
we have over 70 contributors
from 17 different companies
working on it today.
And we want to make sure it
truly does run everywhere,
and so if you find that there
is a machine learning problem
that you're running into today,
we would love to hear about it.
JAY SMITH: We're on GitHub.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Exactly.
And so with that, that's a wrap.
You know, like I said, we have
all the various places for us
to reach out, and
I think we're going
to take just a moment to
collect the questions.
JAY SMITH: All
right, we're back.
So let's go into
some questions here.
What does the adoption of
Kubeflow look like in the wild?
DAVID ARONCHICK: So the
reality is, I wasn't joking.
Kubeflow is a 0.1
release right now.
We would actually not recommend
using it in too many production
workloads right now.
That said, we have heard
many, many stories,
and you can go and check out
the Kubeflow.org website coming
soon.
Not quite available yet.
Or our GitHub repo to
see a number of places
that people are using it today.
In the examples directory,
you will already
see a great number
of examples there,
a solution around GitHub
summarization, GitHub issue
summarization, the tensor
is obviously built in,
and a number of
other ones where you
can download and
start experimenting
with Kubeflow today.
JAY SMITH: Awesome.
So does Kubeflow run on GKE?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
So the demo that you saw
there was Kubeflow running
on Google Kubernetes engine.
And it obviously
runs great, and it
takes advantage of
all the elements
that are available in Google
Cloud, node pools, preemptible
VMs, GPUs, TPUs,
so on and so forth.
But like I said, it really
does run anywhere on Google,
excuse me, Kubernetes runs.
And so that might be
another cloud or on-prem.
But obviously, we think that
we can do a pretty good job
serving Kubeflow on GKE.
JAY SMITH: Of course.
Oh, here's a very
interesting one.
When would I use Kubeflow
over Cloud ML Engine?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
So this is a question
we get a lot,
and the reality is, is
a cloud machine learning
engine is fantastic.
We strongly recommend it.
What we have found, though,
is that oftentimes, a data
scientist might want to
swap out or need something
in a hybrid or on-prem solution.
And in those cases, that's when
you would want to swap out.
So basically, the summary is,
if you'd like a hosted solution
where you really don't have
to think about anything
under the hood, you just want
to hand a model to something
and get back an answer
or use it for inference.
Cloud machine
learning is fantastic,
and we would strongly
recommend it.
If you have customization, or
you want to do on premises,
or you want to do
a hybrid scenario,
Kubeflow would be your best bet.
They really do layer over
each other very nicely.
JAY SMITH: Right.
So right tool for the
right job kind of thing.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
JAY SMITH: If I am an ML, data
scientist, how will Kubeflow
simplify my daily life
rather than complicate it
by adding the Kubernetes layer?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
You know, I think one
of the biggest things
here is that a lot
of data scientists
really want to operate
at that next level up.
I mean, I can't tell you
how many data scientists--
I was just talking with a
fantastic researcher last week
who literally couldn't reproduce
their experiment from a year
ago because the versions
of Python had changed,
and they weren't
sure what happened,
and their library
dependencies had failed.
Kubeflow allows you to
describe your entire framework
in a containerized,
hermetically sealed, dropped
in amber kind of scenario,
and really detail it forever.
And so that's something that you
can share with your colleagues.
You can put it in
a research paper,
all those various things.
And it means you also don't
have to solve all the problems
under the hood.
You don't have to deal
with service discovery.
You don't have to deal with
provisioning persistent disk.
You don't have to deal
with attaching drivers
and GPUs and things like that.
Kubernetes takes care of
all that stuff for you.
Now, that said, if you
are just experimenting
and you want to use a single, we
call it kitchen sink container,
that can be perfectly fine.
What we found,
though, is more often
than not what happens is
that, immediately following
that experiment, a
data scientist has
to completely rewrite
their entire model,
completely rewrite all
their dependencies,
and set up, and have
a lot of trouble even
reproducing the experiments they
were doing in the first place
because that experiment that
they were running initially
is no longer production ready.
And that's where we hope
to make a lot of distance
with Kubeflow.
Kubernetes is very,
very easy to set up.
It comes in Docker,
it has a mini cube.
It's set up, and
then you can deploy--
you can describe and deploy your
entire framework of Kubeflow
onto that local
cluster, and that
is a production ready solution.
That's something you
can take elsewhere.
JAY SMITH: Very good, yes.
Kubernetes, there
is a little bit
of a learning curve with it,
but it's pretty easy to set up.
And again, it's much
easier, as you mentioned,
to control versus learning how
to manage YUM or app repository
and get all the right
dependencies and everything.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Yeah.
I mean, the demo you
saw today was totally,
you know, live, real demo.
And you saw no
Kubernetes commands.
Literally none, other
than just to show off,
you know, that something
was actually running.
All the systems were
running and trying
your model were built in and
out that data science layer
that you're all familiar with.
JAY SMITH: All right.
Looks like we got one
more question here.
What about data in
model versioning?
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely.
That's something
that's very actively
being discussed in the
Kubeflow community right now.
We have heard this
request a lot.
This is something where we
really do want to empower
the community to make these
decisions and help think about
what should come in
the box and what isn't.
Kubeflow isn't trying to
solve a lot of these problems.
We're really packaging
the best of breed
that's out there today.
And so in many of
those discussions that
are happening right now in
the cloud or, excuse me,
in the community,
you are seeing folks
begin to come up with some
norms about what data and model
versioning should look like.
And when those
norms land, we will
ask people who
want to participate
in those discussions
to snap to those norms.
So it'd basically
say, hey, if you're
going to run a machine
learning or excuse me,
a model version or data
versioning pipeline,
you should do one,
two, three, four.
And as long as any solution
comes along and does one, two,
three, four, it should run fine.
JAY SMITH: Well, that's great.
Well, thank you David so much
for joining us and telling
everybody about the
wonders of Kubeflow.
Hopefully, we can get some
people to start using it
and start contributing.
And we want to
see all those pull
requests coming into GitHub and
also hear your success story.
So it's definitely
been great to have you.
DAVID ARONCHICK: Absolutely,
thank you so much.
JAY SMITH: Well, thank you
very much for watching,
and please tune in to
Tuesday's Cloud OnAir next week
and every following week.